here mayor flat open couple of years ago
several years ago
and i described like making the port
rating before the game that
in his chess education
one thing is missed he's not playing any
kind of dynamical chess he tries to
avoid any kind of messy positions he's
very very classical educated and i think
this game would depends on the point uh
if magnus will manage to create kind of
mess on board or
prague will
slowly squeeze from maybe slightly worse
position to kind of style his use to
play
uh the four yeah i think magnus choice
of e3 move avoiding of all kind of
scimitar typical openings trading half
of the pieces
telling the same so he wants to get as
more pieces as possible as more
unstable structure as possible we
clearly will see ore hanging pawns or
isolated pawn pretty soon so uh now all
depends on
uh magnus choice and uh prague style of
position or not because some types of
chess it's not easy to play for prague
yeah i think you've nailed it there
actually when i lost to pride when i
when he was 12 it i was actually better
for most of the game i turned down a few
draws but it was an endgame very
technical and he was great there using
his classical education but
i played him recently last year and i
i actively tried to make it more dynamic
and he was very very uncomfortable and
actually that game i was
a move or two away from winning so yeah
i think he's definitely still has some
weaknesses um which he will uh paper
over over the next few years and uh
meanwhile magnus trying to keep as many
pieces on the board in order to head for
those dynamic quarters so a couple of
trades so far this is still quite a
well-known position
and
the usual move here is knight takes pawn
in the center just to ensure black has
an isolated pawn something a bit
long-term but magnus i was about to say
i just have a feeling he was going to
recapture it with his own pawn and this
is exactly the same pawn structure we
saw earlier today between kostenyk and
magnus but their colours were reversed
and this time though white is slightly
more active
than christianity was yeah
i expect
delivery bishop on g5 knight only 5
magnus wants to be on the pressing side
he wants to go more central and uh
clearly he wants to use the advantage of
the first move so this is the symmetry
but uh compared to the game versus
kostinuke
he didn't spoil a single tempo in the
position wow
and uh he was talking about symmetry
there and i was going to say the top
move is actually to copy white and you
can see pragananda he knows his stuff
and he's following a suit
yeah everything is symmetrical pretty
much apart apart from the placement of a
couple of bishops so uh yeah magnus
meanwhile taking control of the only
well one of the only open lines in the
position
and we'll pronounce copy try and trade a
set of rooks off on this open file or
will he bring his light squared bishop
out
quite a fair amount of choice here um no
right or wrong answer but either way
roughly balanced position and it will be
interesting to see how magnus tries to
outplay his young rival in such uh in
such symmetry it's not going to be easy
such positions do have a reputation of
being very very balanced yeah how strong
is uh young prague in online
rapid
you know what do we know about him in
this format i mean judging from the
challengers tour last season um from
where he qualified for this uh this
champions chess tour he's great yeah i
mean he's very good up until that point
i was a bit unsure he seemed not quite
at his same level over the board i think
because he is classically trained uh but
online especially over the last six
months i think he's been playing much
much better and in the challengers tour
it took him a while to warm up but uh in
the finals there he i think he beat
vincent keimer in the final uh three-nil
he just uh overpowered most of his young
rivals there so
impressive player in general i think the
online offline thing doesn't affect him
so much the young generation they've
grown up with online chess they're
pretty much accustomed to it at this
point is he basically the best 16 year
old in the world
probably
but because uh abdu satorf and kamer are
a bit 17
yep yeah they're seniors and felucia is
eighteen as a pencil nineteen so we're
talking sixteen stop it kai you're
making us feel old
well i feel old david
no they're very good yeah and uh i'm
sure we'll hear those names for the next
ten years battling for ascendancy and a
lot must happen in those years 16 i mean
i know these players become grandmasters
when they're 12 13 but but still a lot
must happen in those years leading up to
you when you turn 20
in your teens late teens you need
stability you need focus i mean some of
them might continue education i guess at
this point they're pretty much focused
on professional chess but they might
choose to do other things you never know
at this age um yes i feel guilty
sometimes we put so much pressure on
their shoulders we expect so much from
them because they're so good already but
um yeah anything can happen who knows
where they'll be in five years time and
it's very unique in chess it seems as
well because you become such a great
player at such a young age in many other
sports
you're usually into your 20s before you
know pressure starts to put on your
shoulders right
yeah and that's why they have such good
support networks around them i guess you
saw ramesh as well in that interview
kaia and
they have great people just keeping them
balanced keeping them yeah
that's also the opportunity to choose
your life path for the future as younger
you do it it's easier because then you
can concentrate on one thing and you
know that this is your goal and you you
you continue like you're following your
star
uh as younger you do this as easier in
the future yeah to make any kind of
progresses and of course all the guys uh
have the supporters around yeah well and
obviously from country to country
there's differences cultural differences
as well right so uh
well russia for example there's been a
big discussion over the last month with
the very young ice skater 15 years old
competing in the olympics and
there was controversies around it but in
russia is
is it more okay to to start you know
going professional at a very young age
um
i i think so because uh russian system
is trying a little bit similar to china
system trying to define the talented
guys in every type of the sport as
younger as possible and to give them
support uh yeah you've been talking
about uh camilla
yeah with some ice skating rumors behind
and yeah
it's it's always tricky when you're so
young because you really depends uh
depend on the people around
so you can't take your own solutions but
uh in in russia there is the system
which helps you to choose to decide to
to do something that's true
but how much autonomy do you have
in some countries like i'm thinking
russia so for instance you're discovered
as a fantastic chess player
you know how much autonomy do you have
to kind of go hang on a second i don't
want this
oh
no i i think you never say no
if you are discovered as a talented
player you always have to remember that
russia is 150 million country and we are
fighting for kind of flight in the
future with different opportunities if
if you are getting this opportunity from
the sport you never say no maybe after
some
achievements in life after some
career goals achieved you you already
start thinking okay maybe education
maybe uh doing these doing that
some investments changing the
the direction of your life but in the
beginning of course you have sport and
you have your goal and you are talented
you realize this and that helps you to
be special to be different compared to
let's say general society yeah how old
were you guys when you decided that
chess would be the main focus of your
life oh uh i i became russian and world
champion under 10. then european
champions under 12 and 14. so
basically in in my family it was decided
quite early yeah i i had different
problems with my career because i i was
born in a very small region and it was
tough to get any kind of support and
since age of 16 i had to work for myself
i mean to to have a chance to travel to
have a chance uh to to get
coaches and it's uh it's different i'm
i'm pretty old
yeah
david
so
back then uh after 90s like middle of
90s it was different recently system
improved giving some sponsorship to
talented guys even outside sort of
moscow and
the whole country yeah
even in regions back then in my time
when i was growing up uh becoming grand
master
i became grandmaster beating victor
korchnoy in age of 17
and uh
it was something special age of 17
grandmaster now they they say oh 17.
yeah he has to retire already
yeah it kind of feels like that right
they're becoming ground masters at such
a young age and magnus carlsen uh
with a smile on his face a few seconds
ago having a good time it's happening in
this game i mean the bar is uh roughly
to the middle is it looking good for the
young 16 year old and it actually has
all been played before ooh uh it was
played by liam lehrer and uh vidit
uh last year okay 21.
it ended with vidit winning but it was a
rapid game so
the the
[Music]
the game might have been decided later
on rather so
in that game yep okay meanwhile i was
going to say the position hadn't changed
too much it was still symmetry
for the last few turns both sides just
getting ready for the action
centralizing their pieces but now the
pawn structure has changed slightly so
white has parted with the bishop pair
black is the one with the bishop pair
now but black's pawn structure on the
queen side on that left side is a bit
compromised you could imagine white
bringing a knight round parking it in
front of black's pawn the one that has
just moved and you have some potential
targets for magnus later in the game i
guess this is just his strategy to
imbalance things slightly and hope that
later on he can go for the right peace
trades maybe outmaneuver pregnant but
uh you again you talked about his
strengths his weaknesses the young
indian do you think this position suits
those strengths uh at least he's not
under the attack by the way i have to
mention that
it is the day to day of b3 and b6
squares so we we often see the queens on
on the queen side actually on the left
side and uh
a previous game with such a queen magnus
managed to to get a mate uh to to
deliver the mate to to kostinuke we will
see what's happening
yeah in that game white was the one with
the queen on this side of the board and
then black switched the play to the
other side so will we see maybe magnus
try and switch the play somehow while
black's queen's off on an adventure
maybe white will switch the play later
towards the black king and uh
still takes a while to prepare um the
other maybe more obvious plan would be
to bring the knight to the side of the
board hit the black queen and then later
on try and park it in front of the
blackboard
this would be a kind of outpost where
blacks pawns cannot challenge it and
also a long-term weakness on this square
but for now black is fine dynamically
there are compensating factors for this
weak uh backward pawn this guy though i
think will be on magnus's sights for the
next few moves
okay
i like your last plan david because to
me that's very thematic because i'm kind
of looking at that pawn structure and
going hang on i recognize that one it's
very similar to like a the kind of pawn
structure i'd get from the karakan which
i love by the way if you don't play the
karakan you should this opening is a
direct transposition from the
karakanyavanka this yeah exact opening
i'm i'm wondering whether that vidic
game was the kara khan
itself
because i've had this position well
basically this position just a few small
differences from your favorite opening
so that's why in chess we've got to
study all openings this game started
with one d4 but it transferred over to
another
opening and magnus has gone for this
nightmare hitting the black queen
and it'll be interesting to see where
the black queen goes actually
um a few choices uh here for pragnanda
yeah i'm still wondering what magnus was
laughing about we never find out no but
you know it was very interesting point
because i was listening to uh to a
podcast uh talking about play and the
effect of play and how it can affect
your neuro plasticity and apparently if
you play
and you you do something like this and
you're not so serious you know you lower
the stakes then basically you can
actually
be a lot more creative in your thinking
rather than if you are really like high
stakes then you're going to be so
outcome oriented you're not going to be
able to just look up and kind of be like
beth harmon and just think about all
those unusual options
yeah i heard it from a neuroscientist
yeah there's links to chess as well we
mentioned the seven deadly chess scenes
earlier and there is a sin i'm trying to
remember the exact name but it's where
you'll focus too much on the results and
it causes you to play passively or play
for the draw or worry or stress a bit
too much when you should just be playing
the position in front of you
um but then again you could lose focus
if you're doing what magnus does and
laughing and thinking about other things
after all chess
has to
stay as a game
and to bring the joy and looks like
magnus enjoys and we don't know what
he's thinking about it might be some
some kind of music he listened today
earlier or something like this it's uh
really often when you're concentrated
something appearing to your mind from
sight
but
just uh generally i think he's enjoying
the process at least today and
looks like uh it's it's very easy and
he's now combining both both ways to
play
uh switching the rook same as in
previous game yeah yeah six ranked to
third rank and uh now the queen isn't
under attack or king so so he's
following sort of a recipe today magnus
carlsen yeah maybe because of this he's
smiling actually yeah he he looks like
to the mirror
and he sees his game versus kostanuk
yeah yeah or maybe he remembers david's
words because david liked has told
everyone and i'm pretty sure you also
told him during the broadcast that
magnus you like your rook lifts yeah as
white he always lifts his rooks or he
wants to lift his rooks to the third
rank because they are so flexible as you
have getting mentioned it's combining
this idea maybe towards the black king
but also it can switch across later
towards the other side of the board as
well and team up with its fellow over
here so a very very cunning move there
by magnus and just because of these two
ideas using this square and using this
square pregnant lander has jumped into
the center again this is something that
kustenyuk did right and this knight does
control the two squares that the white
rook wanted to use so in that game
magnus actually pushed a pawn forward
kicking away the opponent's knight and
when that knight retreated he launched a
pawn storm against the opponent's king
so that was with colours reversed and
things are different here this feels a
bit looser than it did against uh
against kassanyak but that type of idea
might be on magnus's mind
honestly i'm not sure because it it
looks like you can push the knight and
then double on c file and how do you
guard the the pawn on c6 ah that's a
good how can you guard it i was looking
at the wrong side i was thinking of the
pawn storm like
uh like the constenic against carlson
game but you're right he can switch over
this uh this way and suddenly some real
pressure on this file especially against
this pawn and black doesn't really ever
want to trade off this knight in the
center because now after the white
bishop recaptures
yeah this night now is dominated and
this pawn it's all about this pawn
actually and there's a nice outpost for
later dark square strategy is how i
always think in my mind when i get this
particular pawn structure why don't you
say light square strategy for black here
because i'm i'm i i have this sin of
egoism
i'm not thinking about my opponent
and i guess black has a weakness white
doesn't so
that's uh that's the only different uh
differentiation differential factor
right now so okay maybe this one we're
expecting
what else can black do maybe you can go
back this way with the black knight
uh just try and create some tricks
against the white king but it does look
a bit superficial
and uh okay maybe some some crazy answer
by f6 yeah because i was treating the
wise moves copycat so these two knights
are both in the center magnus has played
it and you mentioned this one if white
attacks your knight you don't
necessarily need to uh move it you can
attack the white knight and this would
be crazy but it's not pregnant under
style to be crazy like this so he does
instead just react to this attack
against his knight by dropping back in
this way and actually we're calling the
moves quite well we're calling the plans
white is ganging up against this pawn
what will we see from pregnant here it
the computer i was about to say might
say 0.0 but still a lot of life left
right now but suddenly i've reacted yeah
very badly
as well it's reacted on my computer and
i don't see the moves that the engine is
suggesting so i'm gonna take a peek
it says black is much much better and it
says because black can simply play the
queen to either the b7 square or the b5
square
that is not obvious and it's a really
hidden obvious uh hidden option like uh
simply
uh tell okay take the pawn but i take
back yeah yeah i take the piece back the
whole idea is that you get the black
queen out of the eye line of the white
rook once the white rook captures this
pawn so if you retreat or move to any
square then now as uh you have gunny
mentions takes and at the very end
bishop takes knight and this rook has
been destabilized and will just drop off
on the next turn so very very sneaky
actually not obvious at all this move um
just getting the queen off the sixth
rank putting it on one of these two
squares and i guess he finds it wow
right now i was gonna say i guess the
reason black is better here is because
suddenly this is a bit of a threat and
there's some tension along this diagonal
white king's slightly airy now that
you've pushed some pawns and there's
another problem the knight can actually
come to the e6 square and start looking
at the isolated pawn
yep i'll leave my arrows again just
getting confused there but you're right
you've anchor
lots of moves here for magnus to worry
about this pawn push
this knight retreat
and uh in some variations as well maybe
a sacrifice even on this square
but uh yeah it's not easy enough for
carlson i just asked myself how is
possible how possible to find queen b7
generally
like
uh this move for first you look for some
defensive moves then you perhaps look
for some captures but then this
intermediate move or kind of silent move
comes queen b7
uh giving the temp before for the
opponent and uh the answer is perhaps is
is easy
there is no other option he simply
calculated all other opportunities and
he found this move
so uh there is no other other option and
uh i remember the advice from victor
korchner he gave me
uh many years ago back in 2005 uh i i
complained we played for the same team
and
i complained to victory which i didn't
manage to to beat like a weaker opponent
what
how it possible and he answered
you simply did not give him the chance
to play
give him the chance to make the mistake
so don't force him to take the only
solutions this is what i remembered from
this move like queen b7 but that's very
instructive you you keep saying it david
he has too many options right now it's
that's his biggest problem he has too
many good moves yeah it's no coincidence
that's when the blunders happened that's
when the mistakes happen when you give
your opponent the choice and i've been
there in those exact same shoes yeah
the number of times i've forced my
opponent to play well just they only
have one move by process of elimination
they realize every other move is losing
so they have to play that one and
actually they play a great game but
that's because i've forced them to play
a great game and sometimes you just have
to take a step back and just maneuver
play a slower game give them all that
choice and
yeah
right now pregnant he did find that
great move because he had to
just by process of elimination and
magnus retreating with his bishop there
just preempting that bishop maybe being
attacked also that white bishop now
protected at least by white's king and
pragnando followed through with ivanka's
idea of dropping the knight back
black's pieces blacks minor pieces the
knight and two bishops they're nicely
centralized now
and magnus
i don't know what his avenue of attack
is next i would be very tempted to be
honest to just bring my white rook
across one square attack the black queen
and when the black queen moves just
bring the rook back and hope that the
position repeats itself but black is
maybe no longer forced
uh to continue repeating so i i'm sorry
to ask
i am sir to ask how am i losing in case
i grab the pawn knight takes c6 oh good
question
i i i first
you know i'm hungry
i want to eat the porn on c6 is it
hungry or greedy
so woof okay so taking this porn sorry
after the white uh black knight
retreated taking this pawn
um i guess the most obvious move is to
take this bishop with check gain a bit
of time
and now how can we profit from this
knight temporarily being a bit clumsy
there is a threat in the position if
black does nothing
of drop jumping in the check
and no matter which way black captures
with the queen or the rook suddenly this
rook would be up for grabs and white
wins material but black does have half a
move because one move all right
probably it is this one
uh now suddenly you protect this rook uh
in one extra way so there's no tricks
and black does have ideas of jumping
into this square attacking both of the
white rooks at the same time black has
ideas of jumping in with his rook
towards the white king
suddenly we could see like a
mirror image of castenia against carlson
but carlson being on the defensive
suddenly his king being
the target in an almost symmetrical
position
but then 95 i still try to fight a
little bit i was uh just as i was
talking i was wondering what the answer
is and we're going to find out
okay same idea but prague finds a
different way so i mentioned this one as
almost automatic but prague said no he's
going to plonk his knight in here first
so actually this is an even bigger
threat because now it comes with check
and this is very very clever
that's a huge threat if you ever try and
eliminate this knight then suddenly it
just gets replaced by a bishop hitting
this rook
white's rook is under attack this knight
is a bit loose
but can you not now return materia
return material by the same manner just
put the knight back into the center of
the board um in the current position uh
yep
yep maybe you have to bring the knight
back and magnus has done it just to cut
coordination with this rook and this key
square on e2 so okay let's go back to
the players we might well see some
liquidation some trades now
i'm extremely surprised by the speed of
prague playing these uh moves like
bishop to xc5 it's very very critical
position and he he could simply try to
think at least for two minutes there are
some forks only two there are some maybe
sacrifices in the position their capture
on c3 so there there are too many
opportunities and he's speeding up by
grabbing the knight 25 uh simply leading
maybe to some of of course to some
compensation by knight d3 but i i mean i
i believe in a guy but i can't i can't
believe that he clearly calculated
everything for 10 seconds what's
happening on board so maybe partially
missing the critical moment now magnus
can uh trade the rooks on c8 play rook
c3 and there are no single check on the
dark squares so i i think he he would
feel comfortable at least one up at
least nothing blundered
and
game continuous yeah i have a feeling we
might see all of the rooks exchange
uh on this square there we go and uh
this is a bit of a beast this night but
as you mentioned white is a pawn up so
at some point white might just want to
consolidate bring this bishop forward
park the king on a dart square and
what's the worst that can happen for
white probably you just lose the pawn
back and it fizzles out towards equality
um so you're right you have guinea it's
just okay there we go the bishop does
move forward the king needed a safe
haven away from this diagonal so uh it's
gonna find
uh safety there and
yeah it's a stylistic thing pregnant he
just wanted to keep things simple no
risk no big calculations he just saw
okay he can get a decent position uh
with this transition with knight d3 and
all these moves you mentioned but uh
maybe that was more but ending up with
pawn down so and has to defend of course
uh obviously opposite color bishops the
light square bishop of black is
extremely nice pawn on e5 is weak knight
of white a little bit too far from
everything happening on board
uh however pony exponent and
in case magnus would regroup the pieces
to get knight back in play he's
his favorite in the game yeah so
pragnando still needs to be energetic to
save this game
uh yeah let's go back to the players i
wonder how happy they look
magnus probably laughing
just enjoying being a porn up enjoying
the moment but uh prague yeah still some
work to do
it's unclear uh whether he has full
compensation the computer the evaluation
bar thinks that black is okay here i
would be inclined to agree it just feels
like he's active enough but um the next
plan is the important one
yeah but uh i agree with you white is
able to kind of consolidate a lot more
easier like put the king in the corner
excellent then move the queen up one
square and then move the knight back and
then
yep i guess just keep waiting black does
have the only past pawn in the position
like central port and as basse can push
and now that does prevent white's knight
rejoining the action any time soon
um so this kind of
combination of black's knight black's
pawn behind it black's bishop they do
create a bind
um this is the type of position where if
you talk to the neural network engines
like alpha zero maybe they'll say okay
black is doing great because white's
knight is dominated on the edge of the
board one bad piece
uh makes a position bad who said that
but uh yeah either way
i think that might be something
that's definitely a phrase
[Laughter]
but either way yeah right now it's it's
uh still anything can happen well one
game has uh finished uh jana pognati has
won his game against alexandre costeno
it's an incredible score for yonder
publicity he lost the first game in the
tournament but after that one two three
four five six wins and one draw that's
an insane score he is in top of the
table with 19 out of 24 possible points
how impressed are you with the iam in
this tournament so far
um he's in his style yeah
with uh such approach to chess it's
possible to lose but you clearly one day
would convert more
so he he he's playing in a style he he
likes he's very fast he's creating the
uh problems to the opponents uh so and
seems seems he's enjoying when he's on
uh bright side of life when he's uh
having eager to win from game to game he
is extremely dangerous this is what i
know i mean i i have maybe the worst
score against nepal minister really yeah
in in my life like my minus four or
minus five uh compared to other top
players where i'm not so bad
and uh
i i think he's in in the position uh to
to play with
uh with a great mood also for tomorrow
so even he uh objectively very near uh
to
qualify for uh for the
uh quarterfinals oh definitely yeah and
i guess that is the thing with him he is
known to be an emotional player and that
goes for both bad emotions like in the
world championship match but also the
good emotions when he's playing great
yeah when it's going well it goes very
very well yeah but uh yeah as we saw in
the world championship when it's
when he's not feeling 100 when he's
feeling um a bit unstable then it can go
quite badly
so uh yeah maybe one of the new
favorites for the tournament jan
no matter what happens he's going to be
in top of the table after the second day
in the preliminaries and this one though
can magnus get four out of four today is
there still a big chances for him in
this game
um yet to be seen is still pretty much
what evgeny said it's black is being a
pawn down and it's not clear what
black's next plan is what his next moves
are but then again white does have
problems untangling especially um
deciding when to retreat the white
knight when to bring it back into the
action because if the knights disappear
maybe the game just slowly glides
towards a draw and black central pawn as
well still pretty dangerous
nice yeah i i'm just worried that it
might turn like a force draw now after
queen trades on c1 because uh the the
pawn of magnusson beatrice kind of
hanging in most of the lines at least
what i'm very worried about and he uh
prague would clearly grab the pawn on e2
do you think pregnant wants the draw
though do you think he's playing for
more i don't think so no you think he'll
be happy take that draw and escape from
this game
um i'm hoping that he plays on come on
prank don't trade the queens don't bring
your queen down deliver that check and i
agree that one looks like it's pretty
much
guaranteed guaranteed to be a draw if
the queens do come off because black
will gain the pawn back and it is a draw
between artemyev and duda the two 23
year old rivals they've been rivaled
since they were kids and their game
ending up in a draw here so they are
finished for today and uh
how are they doing uh dude has had a
little bit of uh a bad day hasn't he
it's been up and down for duda the whole
tournament so far um yet to hit his
stride
yep two losses uh in a row uh in the
start of the day for him and then
two draws so he is now an eight out of
24 points currently outside the top a to
qualifies for the knockout he's gonna
have to have a good day tomorrow to have
chances to qualify
now a moment of truth in this game is
prague thinking about the extra money
bonus that we've given
yeah you're thinking about the fighting
chess index that badge of honor for
chess players to be at the top of that
uh fighting chess stats okay he's not
taking he's not taking the kind of easy
way out yet he's just maneuvered his
king to a slightly safer square maybe a
light square
um
i don't think it was necessary i mean
i'm not a big fan of that move because
that king is one square further away
from the action from the center yeah so
if the queens come off exactly then that
king also gives time for white to escape
with king h2 there are no exchange of
queens on c1 anymore and
magnus is getting opportunity to to get
queen and play finally we are e5 some
jumps possible so i after such a long
thing i don't
just generally when you are going down
to two minutes versus eight minutes you
already have to think how to keep
possibilities as easy
uh as you can and
somehow king h7 move is out of this plan
yeah and let's just show the alternative
this queen check would have forced the
queens off the board and this game would
most likely
steer towards the draw just because this
pawn is under attack if you move it the
other pawn falls and um most likely
these pawns will disappear at some point
maybe white can corral and kind of
get this black pawn in the center but
this game would definitely fizzle out
and okay instead if we fast forward
after bringing the king to the side this
allowed white to escape as well now as
you mentioned as well white queen
getting active
and maybe going pawn hunting if possible
that being said black does have some
activity of his own at some point black
can think about trying to get in with
his queen it's still hard to imagine
getting through breaking through to the
white king because this is such a good
defender this bishop it kind of controls
anywhere that black knight wants to jump
but then again black does have some
activity with his queen this pawn as
well if the black knight could find
somewhere to move um you could imagine
it marching down the board so still in
the balance but as you mentioned you're
getting maybe the practical decision in
light of the clock times would have been
just to take the queens off and go for
the draw
and his and talking about uh past pawns
i mean can just he just go for it
and move the knight out of the way push
that pawn onto a light square
which is square
yeah
there was only one there was only one so
that was go to the first row and david
has put it up yeah i mean this is very
tempting to me as well because you could
imagine a situation where white gets
greedy the black knight comes in
obviously white will try and stop this
but then there would be some checkmating
threats okay queen c5 possible so you
can you can still keep the control yeah
at least it's very very dangerous and uh
clearly prague has no time to calculate
all the opportunities so he must
continue by hand and we will see which
intuition is better there is only one
fret on g1 mate potentially after the
knight replacement and but the queen
from a7 grabbing on d4 and controlling
g1 squares or stopping
so now magnus considers to take the pawn
or not to take yeah is greed good we've
been asking ourselves that a few times
now and
white could go two pawns up hitting a
third pawn
it's uh it's definitely tempting right
yeah i mean especially if your
opponent's only got one and a half
minutes especially if you don't see a
threat
we were talking about that earlier right
you ask your opponent well you ask
yourself what your opponent's ideas are
if you don't see anything why not grab a
pawn and hit this pawn in the center
what is black intending queenie iii
c1 knight e2 wow okay the long way round
get round this way and we're going to
find out the truth and yep you called it
process of elimination again after
white's queen took this pawn like had to
bring the queen back defending its pawn
in the center and also maybe hitting
this one it was not a blunder from the
magnus side he's supposed to deliver the
knight back to the center by knight b6
knight d5 options or knight b6 knight c4
options so he clearly would keep control
over the center and the last piece is
out of play for white at the moment is
night
and uh yeah this is what i expect him to
do
and uh with that knight on d5
or over the night maneuvering itself to
a different square i mean the czech
mating ideas that black has on the dark
squares are going to be covered yeah
true because i'm attacking the queen and
knight is not in time to get to e2
so
after i move the queen away i have some
time to regroup or to control d2 square
by bishop f4 and i'm pulling up i'm two
pawns up i'm sorry i'm not talking about
some extra options like e6 sacrifice and
then bishop e5 just coming to the king
magnus is back back in play yep if the
queen's come off now white is most
likely going to win um well if you can
arrange it in a favorable way because of
these two connected past pawns
so uh yeah magnus he just needs to find
a way to re centralize this knight maybe
decentralize this queen at some point
and
but wait one second i mean we've been
talking about like okay i can go on a
journey but there is a threat in the
position which is just to take the pawn
yeah and i i didn't blunder the pawn but
i blundered the next that there is the
perpetual on f3 right
yeah
that that's the point
so for example if the white knight steps
back
then
knight takes pawn
and potentially a draw it's still not
100 clear
but the white king is in a bit of
trouble maybe you can even take here as
black and white's king is going to be so
open especially on the light squares oh
imagine some trouble here and okay
magnus finds a really flashy way to
bring his knight back into the action oh
look at the bar yeah is this clever or
is this madness the white knight coming
back trying to use the fact there's a
pin on this diagonal so black cannot
take this night yet
why are you not reacting more david is
this just the computer going forward
it's like kind of blunder according to
machine no yeah it isn't blunt according
to the machine maybe it's just this
exact variation we were showing just in
a different way why can't black just
step back take that pawn with his knight
in the center and this idea of
okay actually prague finds the best move
i was about to say stockfish the
computer had three suggestions there the
move i mentioned taking that white pawn
would have been fine for black but this
is even better
wow and look at the 16 year old now he's
you know he's bopping his head
he seems to be sensing that this is good
yeah because look at white's night now
suddenly it's kind of threatened white
tonight doesn't have anywhere good to
jump and also black has this idea of
bringing the knight forward later on
this checkmating pattern we showed
black's knight coming to the e2 square
and black's queen trying to deliver
checkmate to the white king and it seems
magnus only has one okay move right now
wow you're right kaya stockfish confirms
it white's only move to survive and stay
in the game
is to bring the white knight back to the
d1 square hitting the black queen
everything else you can pretty much
resign is that natural yes yes that's
the only move okay and if you are forced
to find the only move you usually find
it okay it's like you said uh like
caution i said you force your opponent
to find the only moves and the other two
moves that were suggested there by the
computer were nonsensical they would
have just been uh huge blunders so um
okay white's knight
this is really hanging by a thread now
for white white tonight has blocked the
second rank black was threatening a
nasty checkmate
look at this prague
i think the pace of his moves as well
and creating threats on every turn
yeah i mean i didn't react earlier
because i was struggling to understand
by now i understand white's queen is
just too far offside it was just greed
and uh how do you get her back in time
this looks very good for black now well
he's very scary for white
also the bishop on gtri all the time
hanging i can attack with a queen where
g5 or e1 all the pieces are pinned
knight on f2 misplaced and we should
never forget about the d pawn just
imagine for a second that we trade all
the minor pieces out from word then the
d pawn comes and uh doesn't matter if
your two pawns up in queen and games or
free pawns up as faster your only passer
as uh better it is and uh yeah you can
you can read magnus now he he clearly
doesn't like the position i
um your queen moved to the first row
that looks to me very deadly because it
threatens checkmate and
is there a way to prevent
you know just to prevent this being
checked mate maybe creating some air for
the king running with the pawn or
it's difficult to see what to do i'm
struggling to even find a defense here
for white and magnus clearly struggling
as well um as you mentioned your banker
the big big threat in the position is
the black queen coming down to the first
rank there are two safe squares actually
on that first rank and both of them look
deadly
um there is only one potential loft is
on h3 for the right but it will never
happen because of bishop f5 like uh
bishop will give them eight after all
uh-huh or or the bishop can trap you and
trap the king yeah white would love to
pick up his queen and teleport it back
somewhere to the first rank
just to offer some trades or um just to
create some safety but no okay magnus
does try and create that air for his
king but as you guys mentioned the only
escape square for that viking is up the
board on a light square 8.5
on the bar checkmate is just coming what
happens after black brings the queen
down to the first rank on the e1 square
it's just yeah i mean it's just
checkmate just game over it's just game
10 year old pragnan the youngest player
in the tournament against the world
champion
this could be a little piece of history
in the making i think we've cursed
magnus we didn't follow him today and
then he won all his games as soon as we
followed him yeah right
we followed him with castanek ah true
true but he's about to lose a
sensational game now
and there we go white queen trying to
cover the light squares that's quite
clever uh trying to stop the black
bishop from joining the action and
trapping the white king
but yeah but magnus losing the the piece
after knight g3 queen e5 and potential
bishop f5 check his he's just
gamer like like the simplest uh
way first you have to calculate 40
seconds sure yeah so maybe there are
other moves as well but black's knight
going and capturing the white bishop
wins on the spot as you have getting
points out there there are some deadly
checks white's king is just
in too much peril black could even maybe
just push the pawn forward that would be
tempting as well but knight takes bishop
and look at magnus he's realized he's
about to lose at minimum he's going to
lose a knight checkmate might be coming
as well
no way to save this game
okay he takes a pawn
and
yeah black has plenty of ways to win
this now you can just move the knight
you can give a check you can bring the
knight back
to where it came from
any any any square for now this works
yeah yeah
and white's king only has one safe
square now you have to go up the board
that is not going to be safe wow what a
crazy moment you guys 16 year old about
to beat magnus carlsen
yeah and uh he's just trying to cling on
magnus has literally got his fingernails
now uh just clinging on to that cliff
edge yeah but oh wow what a move black
cuts the coordination between white's
queen and the second rank and is magnus
about to resign is he going to throw in
the towel white knight now
hit by the black queen and if it moves
there's a deadly check in the corner
it's just game over yeah game over wow
has he ever won before pregnant against
magnus carlsen in any official game i
don't think so i don't think i don't
think so it's a historical moment and
it's here magnus carlsen the world
champion loses to 16 year old pregnant
on that look at prague he can almost not
believe it
yeah he's gonna enjoy this moment and
rightly so he played a great game